okay in this video we're going to
discuss autosomal recessive inheritance
this is the genetics pattern uncovered
by Gregor Mendel when he experiments
with pea plants however in this video
we're going to focus on human examples
so let's get started so you might
recognize this picture to be a karyotype
it's a picture of a person's chromosomes
and notice how we have pairs of
chromosomes with a pair of chromosome
number one we have a pair of chromosome
ten well the 23rd chromosome these are
the sex chromosomes and then have a XY
chromosome combination women have the X
X chromosome combination well the other
22 pairs of chromosomes these are called
autosomes and this is where the word
autosomal in the title comes from and
autism is a non sex chromosome meaning
there are no genes at influence gender
the genes that influence gender are
found on the sex chromosomes so an
autosomal disorder is a disorder caused
by a gene found somewhere in the 22
autosomes for instance for instance
sickle-cell disease is caused by a gene
found on chromosome number 11 so let's
in this picture you can see nicely I
think
how sickle-cell disease can actually
affect the person on the left here we
have a vein that branches off left and
right and normal shapes red blood cells
able to freely roll and travel through
these veins and carry oxygen throughout
the body but on the right notice the
sickle shaped red blood cells they're
kind of shaped like bananas this causes
the the red blood cells to be unable to
roll as efficiently they carry less
oxygen they're more likely to get stuck
and clogged in all the twists and turns
and the branching of your veins and
arteries so people with sickle cell tend
to suffer from poor blood circulation
another example of an autosomal disorder
is cystic fibrosis the gene responsible
for cystic fibrosis has been located on
chromosome number 7
and so this is cystic fibrosis is caused
because of a Mis shape and protein you
might remember that proteins are made
from smaller building blocks called
amino acids now the normal cystic
fibrosis protein is made from one
thousand four hundred and eighty amino
acids all chained together and I've
highlighted amino acid 508 for a reason
in just a moment and so if the cystic
fibrosis protein is made properly all
these 1480 amino acids will be attracted
to one another and they twist and fold
and bend into a three-dimensional
protein but people who suffer from
cystic fibrosis they are lacking they're
missing that 500 and a fami no acid so
that one little deletion of that one
amino acid out of the chain of 1480
causes the cystic fibrosis protein to be
altered in in its shape it's not shaped
and formed properly as a result people
who suffer from cystic fibrosis tend to
have mucus and fluid buildup in the
pancreas and in the lungs and can lead
to some very serious health side effects
and one more example of an autosomal
disorder would be PKU or phenylketonuria
the gene for PKU has been located on
chromosome number 12 PKU
is a amino acid problem so in our body
there's amino acid called phenyl alanine
and normally that phenylalanine gets
converted into tyrosine and then
tyrosine barns with a bunch of other
amino acids to make a protein called
melanin people with PKU however lack the
enzyme needed to change phenylalanine to
tyrosine as a result you know alanine
builds up and builds up and builds up in
their in their blood and as a result the
body tries to get rid of all this extra
phenylalanine and some toxins are
produced that can interfere with brain
development and so here's a child being
PKU tested very early after birth it's a
blood test and the blood will be sent to
a lab and
tested and tested for this elevated
amount of phenyl alanine and then
treatment can begin this is the rule for
autosomal recessive inheritance is that
sufferers must inherit two copies of the
defective gene two alleles for the
recessive disorder in order to be
affected that means if i put a key up
here in my animation here that means
healthy is dominant and the disorder
whatever the disorder is whether it's
sickle-cell or cystic fibrosis or PKU
would be recessive and we use lowercase
letters to illustrate recessive alleles
and we use capital letters to illustrate
dominant alleles now here's our woman in
this picture here now there are three
gene genotype combinations that everyone
might be option one she might have two
dominant healthy alleles and remember if
we're looking at PKU this disorder was
found on chromosome 12 so maybe on the
Left chromosome 12 she has a dominant
healthy allele and on the right
chromosome 12
she has a dominant healthy allele this
woman would be homozygous dominant and
she'd be healthy but a second genotype
option
she could be heterozygous meaning on one
of her chromosome 12 she could have
inherited a dominant healthy allele and
on the other chromosome 12 might be the
defected peak a huge PKU gene but
because she has the dominant healthy
allele this woman would be healthy and
then there's the third option maybe she
actually has the disease the third
genotype option here would be homozygous
recessive maybe on each chromosome 12
she has the recessive PKU gene
you know the same is true for men if we
look at PKU as our example there are
three possible genotypes that this man
can be
I'm his chromosome 12 he might have a
dominant healthy allele on the left
chromosome 12 and a dominant healthy
allele on the right chromosome 12 this
man also could be heterozygous where and
one of his chromosome 12s he has the
dominant allele and on the other
chromosome 12 he has the recessive
allele and the third option is he could
suffer from the disorder PKU where on
both chromosome 12 he carries with him
the recessive PKU gene and so if we look
at this dad this man and woman maybe
this man and woman just recently gave
birth to this little girl here and so
let's just pretend that the mom and dad
are tested and they are known to be
heterozygous this means they are healthy
but they have the recessive allele on
one of their chromosome 12 well let's
set up the genotype of the parents and
the outside of our punnett square and
now we complete the inside of the
punnett square and in this top left
punnett square if the capital H capital
H homozygous dominant
combin genotype combination is given
birth to then this child would be
healthy now in the top right of the
punnett square there is a possibility
that capital H lowercase h this is
called the heterozygous combination the
child would be born a healthy although
we would call the child a carrier
because the child carries with them the
recessive allele and they can pass it on
to their future children later on in
life in the lower left hand corner we
have another heterozygous combination
this also would give that would result
in a healthy carrier and in the lower
right of the punnett square we see two
recessive alleles this is the only way
that a person could inherit an autosomal
recessive disorder look at the rule
sufferers must adhere to alleles in
order to have the disease so in this
probability example we can see there is
only a 25% chance that that little girl
would be born with PKU or cystic
fibrosis or sickle-cell or whatever
autosomal recessive disorder you might
be studying okay so here's a practice
problem I want you guys to try to solve
pause the video read through the story
and to the five questions I'm going to
start going over the answers in three
two one so the story says Maria is a
heterozygous healthy female so question
number one what's her genotype well
she's heterozygous she has one capital H
in one lowercase H so I can go ahead and
put Maria onto my punnett square and
then question number two what is Jeff's
genotype what a story says he suffers
from cystic fibrosis that means he must
be homozygous recessive so I can now add
Jeff to the punnett square so now that
both parents their genotypes are known I
can go ahead and fill in the punnett
squares and now once the punnett squares
are completed I can move on to question
number three what is the probability
Maria and Jeff will have a healthy child
of the four punnett squares you can see
two of them have a capital H in them
that means there is a two out of four
chance or a 50% chance that their
children will be born healthy
question number four what is the
probability Maria and Jeff will have a
homozygous dominant child unfortunately
there is a zero percent chance capital H
capital H does not exist in this example
and then question number five what's the
probability Maria and Jeff have a child
born to this life-threatening disorder
you can see that they have a 50% chance
of every child that they have being born
with cystic fibrosis so there you have
Auto zomo recessive inheritance you know
pause the video try to answer these
questions if you're in my biology class
you know I'd be happy to check your
answers before school or after school
one day and if you're watching at home
I'd love to hear your your comments in
the box below thanks for watching